two of the major drags on joe biden's  approval right now are covered  resurgence with delta  for which really republican governors  and anti-vas anti-vaxxers and  anti-masters are to blame more than joe  biden's policy biden's policy has been  get people vaccinated keep schools safe  but i don't deny that ultimately the  buck stops with biden and he has said  that so that's one drag which at a sort  of nitty-gritty level is actually the  fault of mostly republicans the second  drag is afghanistan  so if kovid improves by november of 2022  for the midterms  i believe people will have forgotten  about afghanistan in general foreign  policy impacts voting less than domestic  policy and biden himself is not actually  on the ballot you can see november of 22  as a sort of referendum on joe biden for  sure but this may not really be the end  of the world for joe biden and democrats  in november of 22